Kristy went to one of those high schools for the performing arts, like in Fame , except not good. One of her teachers would leave the room for long stretches to smoke cigarettes, another spent lots of class time gossiping about which celebrities were dating.
克里斯蒂上了一所专门培养表演艺术的高中，就像电影《名扬四海》里那样，不过水平没那么好。她的老师之一经常长时间离开教室去抽烟，另一位则把大部分课堂时间都用来八卦哪个明星在谈恋爱。
One of my music teachers, he never got the memo about separation of church and state. He would talk about Jesus all the time. And he actually would ask, "So, raise your hands. How many of you went to church on Sunday? I bet you would have gone to church if I would have given you extra credit."
我的音乐老师之一，他从没听过“政教分离”这回事。他总是谈论耶稣。他甚至会问：“好，举手。周日去教堂的人有多少？我敢说如果我给你们平时分，你们肯定会去教堂的。”
When a jazz piano class conflicted with World History, her counselor simply signed her out of World History. He listed it on her transcript as a class that she took, but she never actually went to class. It was that kind of school.
当爵士钢琴课和世界历史课冲突时，她的辅导员直接给她退了世界历史课。他在她的成绩单上列出这门课，但她实际上从来没去上过。那所学校就是这样。
She was there to study piano, and that's what she devoted all of her energy to. She practiced after school for four hours to eight hours a day.
她在那儿是为了学习钢琴，她把所有的精力都投入到了这件事上。她每天放学后练习四到八个小时。
Yeah, so I practiced a lot. I mean, I didn't really know much outside the walls of the practice room. And I just really realized, when I got to college, I was way behind. I mean, I didn't even know how to write a paper, you know?
是的，所以我练习了很多。我是说，除了琴房，我对外面世界了解得并不多。当我上大学时，我才真正意识到，我落后太多了。我是说，我甚至不知道该怎么写论文，你知道吗？
But it wasn't exactly in class in college that she realized just how far behind she was. She could fake it in class. It was on stage that she realized, in an improvisational comedy troupe that she joined as a freshman. On stage, her lack of knowledge could be kind of harrowing.
但她在大学里意识到自己落后这么多，其实并不是在课堂上。她在课堂上还能伪装一下。直到她大一加入了一个即兴喜剧团，在舞台上她才意识到这一点。在舞台上，她的无知可能会变得相当可怕。
Like, if someone referred to Henry Kissinger in a scene, I'd just have no idea who that was, at all. The audience would throw out suggestions, like the Hindenburg thing.
比如，如果有人在场景中提到亨利·基辛格，我完全不知道那是谁。观众会提出建议，比如兴登堡号空难之类的事。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
The Hindenburg disaster, yeah.
兴登堡号灾难，是的。
Yeah, and I just had no idea.
是的，我完全不知道。
And then you had to re-enact it on a stage in front of people, and you had no idea what it referred to?
然后你不得不在观众面前的舞台上重现它，而你根本不知道它指的是什么？
I cannot tell you how many times something like that happened, where everybody was laughing and I had no idea why they were laughing. It was really scary, actually, to be honest. I mean, I was so nervous. And I really wanted to stay in the troupe. I didn't want to get kicked out, but I really was so clueless.
我无法形容这种事发生了多少次，大家都笑成一片，而我根本不知道他们在笑什么。说实话，那真的很可怕。我是说，我当时太紧张了。我真的很想留在剧团里。我不想被踢出去，但我确实太无知了。
In one of the sketches they would do on stage, they would ask the audience for a bunch of historical events, and then they would do their own little renditions of these events in the historical order that they happened. And in performing this one day, Kristy confounded her cast mates by putting World War I before the Salem witch trials, but she did manage to locate it after the invention of the wheel.
在他们舞台上的一个小品里，他们会向观众索取一堆历史事件，然后按发生的先后顺序表演这些事件。有一天在表演时，克里斯蒂把第一次世界大战排在了塞勒姆审巫案之前，让她的搭档们大惑不解，但她确实设法把它排在了车轮发明之后。
And after the whole show, everybody was like, "God, Kristy. What was up with that? I mean, why did you start off with World War I? It was the Salem witch trials." They just thought that I wasn't thinking. And I was like, "I didn't know that World War I came after the Salem witch trials."
演出结束后，大家都说：“天哪，克里斯蒂。那是怎么回事？我是说，你为什么要从第一次世界大战开始？那是塞勒姆审巫案啊。”他们只是以为我没过脑子。我说：“我不知道一战是在塞勒姆审巫案之后发生的。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Yeah. They kind of looked at me in disbelief.
是的，他们看着我的眼神里充满了难以置信。
Did you know what the Salem witch trials were?
你知道塞勒姆审巫案是什么吗？
I did. You know what, honestly? You know, I don't even think it's about that. I think it's about that I didn't remember anything about World War I. I thought if it was World War I, it must have happened a long time ago.
我知道。说实话，你知道吗？我觉得重点根本不在这儿。我觉得重点在于我对一战没有任何印象。我心想如果是“第一次世界大战”，那它肯定发生在很久很久以前。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Does that make sense?
这说得通吗？
Yeah. Because the world is so--
是的。因为世界是如此……
Because it's the first war.
因为它是有史以来的第一场战争。
That ever happened. Sure. Absolutely.
确实。绝对是。
It was like, well, invention of the wheel, then it must have been World War I.
当时我就想，好吧，那是车轮发明之后，那肯定就是第一次世界大战。
Right.
对。
I had no idea it happened in the 1900s, you know?
我根本不知道它是发生在20世纪，你知道吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It was the first one.
那是第一次。
Well, I can see the confusion.
嗯，我可以理解这种困惑。
So, to cope with this problem you were having, that you were on stage, you have no idea what's going on, people are laughing at you, and you have no idea why, did you come up with any kind of coping strategy?
那么，为了应对这个问题，当你在舞台上，你完全不知道发生了什么，人们在嘲笑你，而你却不知道为什么，你有没有想出什么应对策略？
I totally did. I came up with some characters that, in their essence, it was OK to be ignorant. So I would use a stoner a lot of times. I'd be like, "Whoa, dude. I have no idea what's going on." And then I would use the troll, which was really my favorite. I would just kind of throw my hair in my face and talk in gibberish. And I'd just be like, Dar! Flar! Figgy floo! Vee floogle ooh! Flogalo vase!, like that.
我完全想到了。我设计了一些角色，本质上就是可以表现得无知。所以我经常扮演一个瘾君子。我会说：“哇，老兄。我根本不知道发生了什么。”然后我会用那个“巨怪”角色，那真是我的最爱。我会把头发遮在脸上，胡言乱语。我会说：“哒！夫拉！菲吉夫露！微夫露果呜！夫洛加洛花瓶！”就像那样。
You'd be in the middle of a scene with another performer, and suddenly that's what you would do? You would just get a stumper?
你会在和另一个表演者演对手戏时突然这么做吗？你会遇到卡壳的时候吗？
Yeah, in every scene, regardless of the time period or setting.
是的，在每一场戏里，不管时代背景或场景是什么。
Does that work?
那管用吗？
Yeah. It works.
是的。管用。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And that's how Kristy turned things around for herself, by pretending to be exactly the thing she was scared she was: an ignorant babbler.
这就是克里斯蒂扭转局面的方式，通过假装成为她最害怕的样子：一个无知的胡言乱语者。
I think that it saved me. I think I was really lost in this troupe.
我觉得这拯救了我。我觉得我在这个剧团里真的很迷茫。
Did you get into social situations that were awkward in exactly the same way that being on stage was awkward, where people would be talking about stuff and you wouldn't know what the hell is going on, and then, basically, you would just turn into the troll?
你有没有在现实生活中遇到过和舞台上一样尴尬的情况，人们在谈论某些事情，你根本不知道发生了什么，然后你基本上就变成了那个巨怪？
I wish that the troll would work in real-life situations, where you're sitting around having a conversation and someone brings up a historic reference that I have no clue, and everyone else is engaged in this, and I just kind of wish I could contribute by going, "Well, fig, floo! Thar! Flar! Dar, de, var, far."
我真希望在现实生活中也能用那套巨怪的把戏，当你坐在一起聊天，有人提到了一个我完全不了解的历史背景，而其他人都参与其中时，我真希望自己能通过说“嗯，菲吉，夫露！扎！夫拉！哒，得，瓦，发”来加入讨论。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But, it doesn't really work out that way.
但是，现实生活中确实行不通。
Well, today, on our radio show, we have three stories of people in the same situation Kristy was in, where people think of them as up for grabs. They're worried about how people will see them, and like Kristy--
那么，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们要讲三个人的故事，他们处于和克里斯蒂一样的境地，人们觉得他们可以随意对待。他们很担心别人会怎么看他们，就像克里斯蒂一样……
Flogalo vase!
夫洛加洛花瓶！
--they take action. They take control of how they're going to be seen with dramatic, drastic steps.
……他们采取了行动。他们通过戏剧性和激进的措施，掌控了自己被他人看待的方式。
Fig! Floo! Thar! Flar! Far!
菲吉！夫露！扎！夫拉！发！
Well said.
说得好。
Flar! Dar, de, var, far!
夫拉！哒，得，瓦，发！
From WBEZ, Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Act One of our show today, Dewey Decibel System. In that story, an American institution calls in the cavalry, calls in very unlikely allies in order to change its own image. Act Two, Goldstein On Goldstein. In that act, Mr. Jonathan Goldstein considers the question of manliness, specifically, his own manliness, and turns to a real man for answers, namely, his dad. Act Three, Heart Shaped Box. In that act, a mom decides that she's going to remake all of the ideas that her son has about his father using a very simple tactic. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天节目的第一幕，“杜威十进制系统”。在这个故事中，一个美国机构召集了援军，寻求一些不太可能的盟友来改变自己的形象。第二幕，“戈德斯坦论戈德斯坦”。在那一幕里，乔纳森·戈德斯坦先生探讨了男子气概的问题，特别是他自己的男子气概，并向一个真正的男人寻求答案，也就是他的父亲。第三幕，“心形盒”。在那一幕里，一位母亲决定用一种非常简单的策略来重塑她儿子对他父亲的所有印象。请继续收听。
Act One. This first story is about an audacious act of rebranding done by a group of people who are not normally thought of as being very audacious at all: public librarians, in this case, teen librarians, the ones who work with teenagers. Alex Blumberg prepared this report last summer.
第一幕。这个第一个故事是关于一群通常被认为一点也不大胆的人所做出的大胆重塑形象的行为：公共图书馆员，在这个案例中是青少年图书馆员，那些与青少年一起工作的人。亚历克斯·布伦伯格去年夏天准备了这份报道。
If you travel among the teen librarians of Michigan, as I did recently, you'll hear a strange phrase over and over again. The phrase is lock-in, like, did you hear how the lock-in went the other night in Kalamazoo? One of the biggest practitioners of the lock-in is a guy named Bill Harmer, the only person I've ever met who could accurately be described as a maverick teen librarian. He explained to me that a lock-in is when the library reopens its doors after closing time, lets a bunch of teenagers in, and then--
如果你像我最近一样在密歇根州的青少年图书馆员中走动，你会一遍又一遍地听到一个奇怪的短语。这个短语是“闭馆留宿”，就像，你听说前几天卡拉马祖的闭馆留宿进行得怎么样了吗？“闭馆留宿”最大的实践者之一是一个叫比尔·哈默的家伙，他是唯一一个我见过的能被准确描述为“特立独行的青少年图书馆员”的人。他向我解释说，“闭馆留宿”是指图书馆在闭馆时间后重新打开大门，放进一群青少年，然后……
Once they come in to the building, they can't leave.
一旦他们进入大楼，他们就不能离开了。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
So they're stuck there until the program's over.
所以他们得待在那里直到活动结束。
So inviting a bunch of teenagers to a library and then locking them in is a fun activity for them?
所以邀请一群青少年去图书馆然后把他们锁在里面对他们来说是一项有趣的活动？
Yeah. They love it. They love it. Every time I've done one, we've had at least 50 or more teenagers show up.
是的。他们喜欢。他们很喜欢。我每次办这个活动，都有至少50个或更多的青少年出现。
It turns out, the lock-in is a state-of-the-art technique in the arsenal of the modern, teen librarian. The library has an image problem. Teenagers see it as the equivalent of summer school: boring, no fun. But Bill Harmer and his colleagues say that's the old library, and they're on a campaign to change people's perceptions.
事实证明，“闭馆留宿”是现代青少年图书馆员库中最先进的技巧。图书馆有一个形象问题。青少年把它看作是暑期学校的同义词：无聊，没意思。但比尔·哈默和他的同事们说，那是旧的图书馆，他们正在发起一场改变人们观念的运动。
Bill has attacked this problem with inspiring devotion. He's had sleep-overs in the library where 50 kids camped out between the stacks. He's hosted late night car tournaments. He stocks the teen section with the latest in Japanese Manga comics and graphic novels. And he's assembled the largest and most comprehensive DVD collection in the entire state, he says, including video stores.
比尔以令人振奋的投入解决了这个问题。他举办过图书馆过夜活动，有50个孩子在书架间露营。他举办过深夜游戏锦标赛。他在青少年区备齐了最新的日本漫画和图像小说。他说，他组建了全州最庞大、最全面的DVD收藏，包括视频租赁店。
But last fall, Bill hatched a plan to take teen library programming to a place it's never gone before, to leave the lock-in in the dust. The plan was this, stage a series of concerts inside libraries all over Michigan, but not the type of music normally associated with the library: acoustic instruments, lyrics about ducks and bunnies, singing puppets.
但去年秋天，比尔想出了一个计划，要把青少年图书馆活动带到一个前所未有的高度，把“闭馆留宿”远远甩在身后。计划就是：在密歇根州各地的图书馆内举办一系列音乐会，但不是通常与图书馆联系在一起的那种音乐：原声乐器、关于鸭子和兔子的歌词、唱歌的木偶。
[MUSIC - "SHOW A SIGN OF LIFE" BY THE HIGH STRUNG]
[音乐 - The High Strung乐队的《Show a Sign of Life》]
No. This would be rock music with electric guitars and huge speakers. This would be, in other words, the state of Michigan's first ever rock and roll library tour. And I know what you're thinking. Libraries: famously quiet. Rock and roll: famously loud. This is the diabolical genius of Bill Harmon's idea: making something appealing by binding it with its exact opposite. Card catalogs packed with Harry Potter and Judy Bloom and this.
不。这将是带有电吉他和巨大扬声器的摇滚乐。换句话说，这将是密歇根州有史以来第一次摇滚图书馆巡演。我知道你在想什么。图书馆：以安静著称。摇滚乐：以吵闹著称。这就是比尔·哈默这个主意的邪恶天才之处：通过将它与它完全相反的东西结合起来，使它变得吸引人。装满哈利·波特、朱迪·布鲁姆和这个的图书卡片目录。
[MUSIC - "SHOW A SIGN OF LIFE" BY THE HIGH STRUNG]
[音乐 - The High Strung乐队的《Show a Sign of Life》]
The song you're listening to now is from the CD of the band that Bill Harmer booked on his library tour, an indie rock trio out of Detroit called The High Strung.
你现在正在听的这首歌来自比尔·哈默在他的图书馆巡演中预定的乐队CD，这是一家来自底特律的独立摇滚三重奏，名叫The High Strung。
We are The High Strung. I'm Josh Malerman. I sing, and play the guitar, and write the songs. Derek?
我们是The High Strung。我是乔什·马勒曼。我唱歌、弹吉他，并写歌。德里克？
Oh, I'm Derek Berk. I play the drums, and I fix the van. And I take care of a lot of reality issues.
哦，我是德里克·伯克。我打鼓，我修面包车。我还负责处理很多现实问题。
He's the treasurer.
他是财务主管。
Yes.
是的。
No, I'm the CFO of the band.
不，我是乐队的首席财务官。
I'm Chad Stocker, and I play the bass. Most of the time we play at rock clubs.
我是查德·斯托克，我弹贝斯。我们大部分时间在摇滚俱乐部演出。
Yeah, rock clubs. It's like, if you can just picture a smoky bar, a lot of drunk people.
是的，摇滚俱乐部。就像，如果你能想象一个烟雾缭绕的酒吧，一群喝醉的人。
With a long-haired sound guy that's probably mad about something.
还有一个长头发的音响师，可能对某事感到愤怒。
The High Strung agreed to the library tour last December, and then they didn't think much about it. But Bill, meanwhile, was going around to library conferences pitching the idea. In the end, he booked 34 library shows, one every other day from June through August.
The High Strung在去年12月同意了这次图书馆巡演，然后他们没怎么把这事放在心上。但比尔，同时，一直在图书馆会议上推销这个想法。最后，他预定了34场图书馆演出，从6月到8月，每两天一场。
When he came back to the band with this information a couple of months later, not only had they sort of forgotten about it, but they'd had no idea it was going to consume their entire summer. I talked with them two days before the tour started, and they were a little freaked out, more than a little.
当他几个月后带着这个信息回到乐队时，他们不仅把这事忘得差不多了，而且根本不知道这会耗掉他们整个夏天。在巡演开始前两天，我和他们谈过，他们有点被吓坏了，甚至不止一点。
I'm terrified. You know that?
我吓坏了。你知道吗？
No. I know. I know. Absolutely. It's like this weird, unknown thing for a band to do because we're not like a novelty act.
不。我知道。我完全知道。这对乐队来说是一件奇怪的、未知的事情，因为我们不是那种噱头演出。
This tour, I think, is geared for sixth-graders to 12th-graders, for the most part, and their parents.
这次巡演，我认为主要针对的是六年级到十二年级的学生，以及他们的父母。
I feel like we're almost going to be like tamed beasts. Watch my language.
我觉得我们几乎要像被驯服的野兽了。注意我的语言。
Don't get too close, kids.
别靠太近了，孩子们。
Cover the liquor up off the breath, you know?
掩盖住呼吸里的酒气，你知道吗？
We should be in a cage.
我们应该被关在笼子里。
Yeah. We are playing inside the libraries most the time. And I went to one yesterday, and the guy showing me, he's like, "This is your stage." And it was, like, the reference desk.
是的。我们大部分时间是在图书馆里演出。我昨天去了其中一个，那个人向我展示，他就像说，“这是你的舞台。”那是，参考资料柜台。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was like, "Oh. Yeah. Where do we plug in?" He was like, "Plug in?"
我说，“哦。是的。我们在哪里接通电源？”他说，“接通电源？”
Josh, Derek and Chad have known each other since middle school. They formed their band about five years ago in New York. Early on, Josh booked a couple of live shows so they could get used to playing in front of people. Once they got on the road, they liked it so much they didn't want to quit. They've been touring non-stop now for four years straight. They've played in 42 of the 50 states to all different crowds. In Austin, Texas, they played to an audience of over 1,000. But a show in New Orleans that they drove all night to get to didn't have a single person. Even the bartender left. There was one guy there, but he was passed out drunk the entire show.
乔什、德里克和查德从中学起就认识了。他们大约五年前在纽约组建了乐队。早些时候，乔什预定了几场现场演出，这样他们就可以习惯在观众面前表演。一旦他们开始上路，他们就太喜欢这种感觉了，不想停下来。他们现在已经连续四年不停地巡演了。他们在50个州中的42个州为各种不同的观众演出过。在德克萨斯州奥斯汀，他们为超过1000名观众演出。但在新奥尔良的一场演出，他们开车开了一整晚才赶到，却一个人都没有。连调酒师都走了。现场有一个人，但他整场演出都醉得不省人事。
They're in the position of a lot of indie bands: some critical recognition, one CD out, another one due this September, a website, something of a following. In short, a teeny bit of fame and not really any fortune.
他们处于许多独立乐队的处境：一些评论界的认可，出了一张CD，另一张定于今年九月，一个网站，还有一些追随者。简而言之，有一点点的名气，但其实没什么财富。
We've been living off $10 a day, each, for four years now.
我们四年来每天靠10美元生活，每个人。
Right.
对。
Which is pretty nuts. No matter how much money we make the night before, we each just get $10 a day.
这真的很疯狂。无论前一天晚上我们赚多少钱，我们每个人每天只拿10美元。
Who decides that?
谁决定的？
Our CFO.
我们的首席财务官。
Me. I decided that three years ago.
我。我三年前决定的。
A brilliant CFO.
一位出色的首席财务官。
There's been no adjustment for cost of living.
生活成本完全没有调整。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He's not very progressive.
他不怎么开明。
No. I mean the dollar menu is still the dollar. Sometimes there's a buy-out, which is exciting.
不。我是说美元菜单还是那个价。有时候有“买断费”，这很令人兴奋。
And that's, when?
那是什么时候？
It's when they give you money. Some places you play at their restaurant too. But, if they don't have food there, they'll either order you a pizza, or something, or a burrito, or [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Or there's the elusive buy-out where they actually give you cash.
就是他们给你钱的时候。有些地方你们也在他们的餐厅演出。但是，如果他们那里没有食物，他们要么会给你点披萨，或者什么，或者墨西哥卷饼，或者[听不清]。或者有那难以捉摸的“买断费”，他们真的给你现金。
That's the best.
那是最好的。
Then you can buy whatever you want.
那你就可以买任何你想要的东西。
Cigarettes and a cheaper sandwich somewhere else.
香烟和别处更便宜的三明治。
Right, and pocket the extra money.
对，然后把剩下的钱揣进兜里。
Yeah.
是的。
I thought you meant you would take the money and go get something really, really good. But you're actually [INAUDIBLE] even worse.
我以为你的意思是你会拿了钱去买点真的、真的很好的东西。但你其实[听不清]甚至更糟。
No. You get something worse than what they would give you so you can save the money.
不。你会买比他们给你的更差的东西，这样你才能省下钱。
I know this is a digression, but one of the things I found most charming about the band is this fact. A while ago, they saw some footage on TV of an old Motown act. Everyone in the group was wearing the same outfit. And they thought, now, those guys look together up there. We should do that. So, a couple of months ago, they started performing every show in identical uniforms.
我知道这跑题了，但乐队最让我着迷的一点是这个事实。不久前，他们在电视上看到了一些老摩城乐队的录像。小组里的每个人都穿着同样的衣服。他们想，看，那些家伙在台上看起来真整齐。我们应该那样做。所以，几个月前，他们开始穿着完全相同的制服参加每一场演出。
Tight, white, really tight, white, outfits with blue stars up and down the sides, you know? If you can imagine Evel Knievel, I guess. And it's more fun for me, man, because I feel like a superhero when we wear those outfits. It separates you from the audience, or something, you know what I mean? It makes you into a television show, or a superhero, or something.
紧身的、白色的、真的很紧的、白色的服装，两侧有蓝色星星，你知道吗？如果你能想象埃维尔·克尼维尔，我想。这对我来说更有趣，伙计，因为当我们穿上那些衣服时，我觉得自己像个超级英雄。它把你和观众分开了，或者别的什么，你懂我意思吗？它把你变成了一个电视节目，或者一个超级英雄，或者别的什么。
So how does that work if you're wearing the same costume every night?
那么如果你每天晚上都穿同样的衣服，那怎么弄？
Yeah. That's a great follow-up question.
是的。那是个很好的后续问题。
That is good. That's a very intelligent question.
那是很好的。那是一个非常聪明的问题。
For the first time ever, I'm really persistent about us cleaning something, because I want to make sure that we always have these uniforms to wear. And they can be outrageous if we wear them for three shows in a row without washing them, so we've just got to find a laundromat in every city, you know? I hang out. These guys don't. I go and do that. And I'm alone at these weird laundromats in every town we go to.
我第一次真的坚持要我们清洗什么东西，因为我想确保我们总是有这些制服可以穿。如果我们连续穿三次演出而不洗，它们可能会变得很离谱，所以我们必须在每个城市找到自助洗衣店，你知道吗？我待在那里。他们不。我去了，在每个我们去的城镇那些古怪的自助洗衣店里做这件事。
Josh is kind of--
乔什有点……
In charge?
负责？
Josh is kind of in charge of cleaning the laundry.
乔什有点负责洗衣服。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Cleaning the get-ups. We call them get-ups. We're like, you got the get-ups? Yeah, they're in the bag. There's a get-up bag, too.
洗那些行头。我们叫它们行头。我们就像，你带了行头吗？是的，在包里。还有一个行头包。
The High Strung, in many ways, are the perfect band for this tour, because they're both very rock and roll and very library. They've all been to college. Chad wears round glasses. Josh says one of his main song writing inspirations is William Faulkner. He actually wrote an outline for his last album in which he describes his 12 songs, each a different take on optimism. And they're huge library patrons, and not just because they like to read.
The High Strung在很多方面是这次巡演的完美乐队，因为他们既非常摇滚又非常图书馆风。他们都上过大学。查德戴着圆眼镜。乔什说他主要的歌曲创作灵感之一是威廉·福克纳。他实际上为他的上一张专辑写了一个大纲，在其中他描述了他的12首歌，每一首都是对乐观主义的不同解读。他们是忠实的图书馆常客，不仅仅是因为他们喜欢阅读。
The truth is, bands, nowadays, are in libraries all the time because there's the internet and stuff there. And when you're on the road, it's a valuable place to go for a band.
事实是，乐队现在一直在图书馆，因为那里有互联网之类的东西。当你在路上时，这对乐队来说是一个很有价值的地方。
Yeah, It's our office.
是的，这是我们的办公室。
It's like the field office.
这就像是实地办事处。
You got internet, and you got a clean toilet with, usually, there's toilet paper and a door that locks.
你有互联网，还有一个干净的厕所，通常有卫生纸，还有一扇能锁上的门。
Wait. Are are you telling me that you guys stop at the library in every--
等等。你是说你们在每一个……都要在图书馆停下来吗？
Yeah. Shave there.
是的。在那里刮胡子。
We do. We usually shave there. Yeah. We're in a lot of libraries across the country.
我们会的。我们通常在那里刮胡子。是的。我们在全国各地的很多图书馆里。
I used to work at the Ann Arbor district library as a security guard there in college.
我上大学时曾在安娜堡区图书馆当过保安。
Oh, my gosh. It was all leading to this.
哦，天哪。一切都是注定的。
And we used to have to kick out people that had their shoes off, or if they smelled too bad and got complaints, or if we caught them cleaning up in the bathroom, and stuff. And then, years later, I'm doing that.
我们以前不得不把那些脱掉鞋子的人赶走，或者如果他们闻起来太臭被投诉了，或者如果我们抓到他们在洗手间洗漱之类的。然后，几年后，我在做那件事。
I don't know if you've risen or fallen.
我不知道你是升华了还是堕落了。
The next time I catch up with the band is at the Escanaba Public Library. It's the band's 25th library in their 34-library tour. And the audiences, they say, have been all over the place. Some have been high school kids, mainly 16- to 18-year-olds. Others, like this crowd, have skewed much younger. It's about 40 kids, mostly between the ages of nine and 14, many of them swinging their legs on those stackable metal library chairs, accompanied by grandparents or parents. The emcee of today's show is the Assistant Children's Librarian, Charlotte Oshe, who does her own librarian version of, hello Escanaba, are you ready to rock?
我下一次赶上乐队是在埃斯卡纳巴公共图书馆。这是乐队34场图书馆巡演中的第25场。他们说，观众的情况各不相同。有些是高中生，主要是16到18岁的孩子。另一些，就像这群人，年龄要小得多。大约有40个孩子，大多在9到14岁之间，许多人摇晃着腿坐在那些可堆叠的金属图书馆椅子上，由祖父母或父母陪同。今天演出的司仪是助理儿童图书馆员夏洛特·奥谢，她用她自己的图书馆员版本说道：“你好埃斯卡纳巴，准备好摇滚了吗？”
Hello, kids. Congratulations for finishing your summer reading program contracts. We are so proud of you. You are here to see a, what?
你好，孩子们。祝贺你们完成了暑期阅读计划合同。我们为你们感到骄傲。你们来这里是为了看一个，什么？
Concert?
音乐会？
Concert. Right.
音乐会。对。
We're in a gray, carpeted conference room off the main floor of the library: fluorescent lights, a white board with a graph showing recent expenditures. This room is normally used for county budget meetings. The band, in regular street clothes for this tour, takes the floor.
我们在主楼层旁边一个灰色的地毯铺地的会议室里：荧光灯、一个展示近期支出图表的白板。这个房间通常用于县预算会议。乐队，这次巡演穿着平时的街头服装，占据了地板。
How cool is it that your library does this, huh? This is awesome. OK. We are The High Strung. Yeah. Clap for your library. This is great.
你们图书馆这样做有多酷，是吧？这太棒了。好的。我们是The High Strung。是的。为你们的图书馆鼓掌。这太棒了。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Here It Comes Again . 1, 2, 3, 4.
《Here It Comes Again》。1，2，3，4。
[MUSIC - "HERE IT COMES AGAIN" BY THE HIGH STRUNG]
[音乐 - The High Strung乐队的《Here It Comes Again》]
The loudness definitely catches people off guard. Kids flinch, startled. Some of them cover their ears. Watching it all, I feel very nervous for the band, for the kids, for the parents who brought the kids, for everyone. When I ask the band about it later, they tell me nobody involved has any idea what to expect.
巨大的声音确实让人措手不及。孩子们畏缩了，吓了一跳。有些人捂住耳朵。看着这一切，我为乐队、为孩子们、为带孩子来的家长、为每个人感到非常紧张。当我后来问乐队这件事时，他们告诉我，所有相关的人都不知道会发生什么。
It's like, what is going on here? You feel like you're in a sociology experiment. This is let's put the loudest thing known to man inside the conference room of the library with a bunch of 10-year-old kids and see what happens.
就像，这里发生了什么？你感觉自己置身于一个社会学实验中。这就是把已知最吵的东西放进图书馆的会议室里，和一群10岁的孩子一起，看看会发生什么。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
There was kids that were scared when we were in Brighton.
我们在布莱顿的时候有孩子被吓到了。
In Brighton?
在布莱顿？
Yeah. Even though we were outside, they still had faces of disbelief. Or they were like, this is not what-- everyone's always telling me to be quiet here. This is not supposed to be happening.
是的。即使我们在外面，他们脸上仍然带着难以置信的神情。或者他们就像是，这不该是……每个人总是告诉我要在这里安静。这不应该发生。
They said that to us, right?
他们对我们说了，对吧？
Yeah. Yeah, almost to where they were angered.
是的。是的，几乎到了他们感到愤怒的地步。
That one girl said that there.
那个女孩在那里说了。
They were angered. Like, everything everyone's been telling me up to this point has been a lie.
他们被激怒了。就像，每个人到现在为止告诉我的所有事情都是谎言。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
[MUSIC - "HERE IT COMES AGAIN" BY HIGH STRUNG]
[音乐 - The High Strung乐队的《Here It Comes Again》]
In the audience, no one dances or even moves, really. They all sit and watch, attentively but a little passively, like the way you'd watch someone reading aloud during story hour. Between songs, the band throws in some public service-y library messages.
在观众席中，没有人跳舞，甚至没有移动，真的。他们都坐着观看，专注但有点被动，就像你在故事时间看别人大声朗读的样子。歌曲之间，乐队会插入一些公共服务式的图书馆信息。
Another exciting thing about libraries are-- and this is something that we need, terribly-- are maps and atlases. This is all reference material. You can check it out, but you can't check it out. You know what I'm saying?
关于图书馆另一件令人兴奋的事是——这是我们非常需要的——是地图和地图集。这些都是参考资料。你可以借阅它们，但你不能把它们带走。你懂我意思吗？
So in these maps, we find our way all over the country. And you can even look up crazy places all over the world. I want to know if anyone has been to Sweden or Venezuela? No. OK. The reason I asked because this next song we made a video for for MTV, and if you lived in Sweden or Venezuela, you may have seen it, because that's the only place [INAUDIBLE].
所以这些地图里，我们找到了遍布全国的路。你甚至可以查阅世界各地的疯狂地方。我想知道有没有人去过瑞典或委内瑞拉？没有。好的。我问的原因是我们为这下一首歌在MTV上拍了录影带，如果你住在瑞典或委内瑞拉，你可能看过它，因为那是唯一的地方[听不清]。
This song is called Wretched Boy. 1, 2, 3, 4.
这首歌叫《Wretched Boy》。1，2，3，4。
[MUSIC - "WRETCHED BOY" BY THE HIGH STRUNG]
[音乐 - The High Strung乐队的《Wretched Boy》]
So here it is, the image of rock and roll and the image of the library going head to head. Bill Harmer hopes that the image of rock and roll will win out and that the library will seem cooler as a result of this bizarre collision. But what if the opposite proves true? The library wins, and this tour does nothing except make the band seem lame?
所以，这就是摇滚乐的形象和图书馆的形象正面碰撞。比尔·哈默希望摇滚乐的形象能够胜出，从而使图书馆看起来更酷。但如果相反的结果被证明是真的呢？图书馆赢了，而这次巡演除了让乐队看起来很逊之外什么都没做？
Basically, you are being sort of retained to make this institution that is not necessarily seen as cool cooler. That's sort of a big responsibility. Do you guys feel cool enough?
基本上，你有点被聘用来让这个不一定被认为是酷的机构变得更酷。这算是一个很大的责任。你们觉得够酷吗？
That's a weird thing. That's a really weird thing.
那是件奇怪的事。那真的是件奇怪的事。
That's the weirdest question I've ever been asked.
那是我被问过的最奇怪的问题。
I think so. I think the public library-- That is a really weird question. I think the public library is really cool.
我想是的。我想公共图书馆——那真是一个非常奇怪的问题。我觉得公共图书馆真的很酷。
Sure, yes.
当然，是的。
But I think that maybe people don't know it, and maybe teens don't know it.
但我认为也许人们不知道，也许青少年不知道。
Are we cooler than the library? No. Are we cooler than the idea of the library? Maybe.
我们比图书馆更酷吗？不。我们比图书馆这个概念更酷吗？也许。
As the show progresses, it seems less and less like a rock show in a library, and more and more like just a rock show. Josh gets on top of a table for his guitar solo and jumps off at the end.
随着演出进行，它看起来越来越不像在图书馆里的摇滚演出，而越来越像是一场单纯的摇滚演出。乔什为了吉他独奏爬上了一张桌子，并在最后跳了下来。
A group of adolescent girls sits in front of Chad, the bass player. He's one of those happy musicians who can't help but smile an adorable smile while he plays super complicated riffs. You can practically see the communal crush develop. Between songs, they flirt with him. One girl complains that her tan this summer came out usually orange and that she looks like an Oompa Loompa.
一群青春期的女孩坐在贝斯手查德面前。他是那种快乐的音乐家，在弹奏超级复杂的乐句时忍不住露出可爱的微笑。你几乎可以看到这种共有的迷恋正在滋生。歌曲之间，她们和他调情。一个女孩抱怨她今年夏天的晒黑肤色变成了通常的橙色，看起来像个奥姆帕·伦帕人。
[YOUNG GIRLS LAUGHTER]
[年轻女孩的笑声]
What?
什么？
[YOUNG GIRLS TALKING ALL AT ONCE]
[年轻女孩同时说话]
Aren't Oompa Loompas green?
奥姆帕·伦帕人不应该是绿色的吗？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉的声音]
Oh. I like their pants. Oompa Loompa's got cool, cool clothes. 1, 2, 3.
哦。我喜欢他们的裤子。奥姆帕·伦帕人穿着酷酷的衣服。1，2，3。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放音乐]
I know the show is going well when, at one point, I notice that Josh has actually broken one of his guitar strings. By the time the head children's librarian comes out and does the librarian version of let's give it up for the band, I said let's give it up for the band, one thing's for sure: this county library conference room has been rocked harder than it's ever been rocked before.
我知道演出进行得很顺利，当在某个时刻，我注意到乔什实际上断了一根吉他弦。当儿童图书馆总管理员出来做图书馆员版本的“让我们为乐队鼓掌，我说让我们为乐队鼓掌”时，有一点是肯定的：这个县图书馆会议室被摇滚得比以往任何时候都要强烈。
Boys and girls, would you truly let these gentlemen know how much we appreciate them? Come on, really let them know.
男孩和女孩们，你们能真正让这些绅士们知道我们有多感激他们吗？来吧，真正让他们知道。
[APPLAUSE AND SCREAMS]
[掌声和尖叫声]
But the question is, was it rocked hard enough to actually change the image of the library? I talked to scores of kids at three different library shows in three different towns. Maybe half are what you'd call library kids, part of the teen reading club, or on a first-name basis with the local librarian. The rest just saw ads in the paper, or their parents did. But everyone talked about the library tour the way this group of teenagers in Iron Mountain did. They're all standing outside the show, wearing black, heavy metal T-shirts.
但问题是，它真的摇滚得足以改变图书馆的形象吗？我和三个不同城镇的三场图书馆演出的几十个孩子谈过。可能有一半人是你所谓的“图书馆孩子”，是青少年阅读俱乐部的成员，或者和当地图书馆员是熟人。其余的人只是在报纸上看到了广告，或者他们的父母看到了。但每个人都谈论着图书馆巡演，就像这群在铁山的青少年一样。他们都站在演出场地外面，穿着黑色的重金属T恤。
So if you had to describe the way you thought of the library before this concert, what would you have said? What were the adjectives that would come to your mind if you thought about that?
所以如果你必须描述一下你在这次音乐会之前对图书馆的看法，你会怎么说？如果想到那个，你会想到什么形容词？
Dull.
沉闷。
Quiet.
安静。
Very quiet.
非常安静。
Activities.
活动。
And now?
那现在呢？
Amazing.
太棒了。
Come on. Seriously?
得了吧。认真地？
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
It's better than it was before, anyways. I liked it.
反正比以前好多了。我喜欢。
Yeah, because before it was just old ladies. Now it's young people.
是的，因为以前只是老太太。现在是年轻人了。
It was a lot of fun.
这真的很有趣。
And then there was this 11-year-old in Menominee, who had planned on going fishing, but decided to check out the rock show instead.
然后就是那个在梅诺米尼的11岁孩子，他原计划去钓鱼，但决定改来看摇滚演出。
Did it make you think differently about the library?
它让你对图书馆有不同的看法了吗？
Yes, it did. It made me think about, hey, if librarians could do this, make a library not very much a library with making it loud, basically, anyone could do anything.
是的，它确实。它让我思考，嘿，如果图书馆员能做到这一点，通过让它变得吵闹，使图书馆不再那么像一个图书馆，基本上，任何人都可以做任何事。
The High Strung are enjoying the library tour as well. Librarians, as a group, tend to be better at organizing and promoting rock shows than actual rock promoters, as well as much more likely to address you as honey. Also, it's the first tour they've been on where they don't have to drive to another state after the concert is over. They've all been spending a lot of time with their girlfriends. And, even though they're playing a library show almost every day, because they're mostly during the day and because they're mostly within driving distance of Detroit, it's been a very relaxed summer and, by their standards, lucrative.
The High Strung也很享受这次图书馆巡演。图书馆员作为一个群体，往往比真正的摇滚经纪人更擅长组织和推广摇滚演出，而且更有可能称呼你为“亲爱的”。此外，这是他们参加的第一次不需要在音乐会结束后开车去另一个州的巡演。他们都有很多时间和女朋友相处。而且，即使他们几乎每天都在演出，因为它们大多在白天，而且大部分都在底特律的开车距离之内，这是一个非常轻松的夏天，按照他们的标准，收益颇丰。
How much are you guys getting paid for this?
你们这次拿了多少钱？
Oh, that's none of your damned business.
哦，那不关你的事。
More than we normally get, I would say.
比我们通常得到的多，我想。
On the high end of average.
平均水平的高端。
High end of average for what we usually make at our shows.
是我们演出通常赚的钱的平均水平的高端。
Yeah.
是的。
And we won't have to wait at the end of the night for some promoter to sell a bunch of cocaine down the street to have enough money to pay for our guarantee. You know?
而且我们不需要在深夜等什么经纪人去街上卖一堆可卡因才有足够的钱来支付我们的保障金。你知道吗？
Overall, the band is surprised how similar the library tour has been to a regular tour, except for one thing. On a regular tour, they don't stick around for a Q&A 20 minutes after every show.
总的来说，乐队很惊讶图书馆巡演和普通巡演有多相似，除了有一件事。在普通巡演中，他们不会在每场演出后留下来进行20分钟的问答。
Some people in this room would like to know if you have a girlfriend, and how old you are.
这个房间里有些人想知道你们是否有女朋友，以及你们多大了。
How did your families take it when you decided to start a rock band?
当你们决定组建摇滚乐队时，你们的家人有什么反应？
Do you guys live together?
你们住在一起吗？
Did you guys read and go to libraries when you were teens?
你们青少年时阅读并去图书馆吗？
Why isn't the drummer wearing any shoe laces?
为什么鼓手没有系鞋带？
I didn't think of this before we started this whole thing, but I really think that, a lot of kids, this is their first rock show, and I did not think of that angle at all when this whole thing started. Like, wow, we really are-- I really remember the first time I saw a bunch of grown men dancing around, making noise together, and people watching. It's like that's an experience. So yeah. And surprised I just never thought of that.
我们在开始这一切之前没有想到这一点，但我真的认为，对许多孩子来说，这是他们的第一场摇滚演出，我在这一切开始时根本没有想到那个角度。就像，哇，我们真的是——我真的记得我第一次看到一群成年男人在一起跳舞、制造噪音，而人们在观看。这就像那是一种经历。所以是的。我很惊讶我竟然从来没想过。
And now, I can't really explain it. The delivery of it all just has a different meaning to me now. It's more weighted or something. Like, oh, wow, this move here, or when I turn to Derek and both of us just do the silliest thing like slam our instruments at the same time, that's going to be an image in that child's mind. They're going to remember that when they remember their first concert, or whatever. So suddenly, things are not weighted with pressure, but weighted with a little more meaning.
而现在，我真的无法解释。所有这些的传递对我来说现在有了不同的意义。它更沉重或别的什么。就像，哦，哇，这个动作，或者当我转向德里克，我们俩只是做一些最愚蠢的事情，比如同时重击我们的乐器，那将是那个孩子脑海中的一个形象。当他们想起他们的第一场音乐会或什么的，他们会记得那个。所以突然间，事情不再充满压力，而是带有了一点更多的意义。
[MUSIC - "CLOWN CAR" BY THE HIGH STRUNG]
[音乐 - The High Strung乐队的《Clown Car》]
The last show I attend is in Menominee, a small town in the far north of the state. The band is playing in the library central reading room. You couldn't make it up any better. It's a beautiful place with big picture windows looking out on the water and a skylight, rows of bookshelves spread out to either side.
我参加的最后一场演出是在梅诺米尼，一个位于该州远北的小镇。乐队在图书馆中央阅览室演出。你编不出比这更好的场景了。那是一个美丽的地方，有看向水面的大落地窗和天窗，一排排书架向两边延伸。
The crowd is the biggest age range I've seen. There's a couple of high school kids with the neo-ska punk look, several middle-schoolers. In the very front row, a kid who can't be more than four years old holding a huge deck of Pokemon cards in one hand and a stuffed bunny in the other. He's covering his ears with his elbows, but he's bouncing wildly up and down on his chair, and he's got a huge smile on his face. A lot of the kids in the audience have a look like that, like I can't explain what I'm watching, but I really like it. When I talk to them about it later, it's hard for them to articulate. "I like the way it made me feel," they say. Or "I like the way one of them will be going one way and one another." Or simply, "I like the way it vibrated on me. That was the funnest part."
人群是我见过的年龄跨度最大的。有几个带有新斯卡朋克风格的高中生，几个中学生。在最前排，一个不超过四岁的孩子，一只手拿着一大叠宝可梦卡，另一只手拿着一只毛绒兔子。他用手肘捂着耳朵，但在椅子上疯狂地弹跳，脸上带着巨大的笑容。观众中的许多孩子都有那样的表情，就像我无法解释我正在看什么，但我真的很喜欢它。当我后来和他们谈起这件事时，他们很难表达清楚。“我喜欢它让我感觉到的方式，”他们说。“或者我喜欢他们其中一个向这边走，另一个向那边走的方式。”或者简单地说，“我喜欢它震动我的方式。那是最好玩的部分。”
Of course, if you're selling teens on the library by saying now it's a place that rocks, then you pretty much have to keep booking rock shows. And Bill Harmer would be fine with that. He'd love it if rock and roll were as common in Michigan's libraries as story corner. His colleagues may take some convincing, though.
当然，如果你通过说“现在这里是一个摇滚的地方”来向青少年推销图书馆，那么你基本上必须继续预定摇滚演出。比尔·哈默对那样做没问题。如果摇滚乐在密歇根州的图书馆里像故事角一样普遍，他会很高兴的。尽管他的同事们可能需要一些说服。
During the show in Menominee, I went downstairs to the check-out desk. All the librarians had their hands over their ears, or shouting at each other to be heard. I asked them how many of these concerts could they stand each year. One of the youth services librarians, a balding man with a mustache, didn't even try to talk over the noise. He just held up his hand with his index finger to his thumb. Zero, he mouthed.
在梅诺米尼的演出期间，我下楼去了借阅台。所有的图书馆员都捂着耳朵，或者互相大喊大叫以便被听到。我问他们每年能忍受多少场这样的音乐会。其中一位青少年服务图书馆员，一个留着胡子谢顶的男人，甚至没有试图盖过噪音。他只是举起手，用食指对准大拇指。零，他对着嘴型说。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[播放音乐]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Alex Blumberg is one of the producers of our program. The High Strung are on the internet at www.thehighstrung.com. It's been a year since Alex did that story. And this summer, The High Strung have expanded to a nationwide library tour: 60 libraries, 42 states.
亚历克斯·布伦伯格是我们节目的制片人之一。The High Strung在互联网上的网址是www.thehighstrung.com。亚历克斯做那个报道已经一年了。而今年夏天，The High Strung已经扩展到全国图书馆巡演：60个图书馆，42个州。
[MUSIC - "SHUT UP IN THE LIBRARY" BY BARRY LOUIS POLISAR]
[音乐 - Barry Louis Polisar的《Shut Up in the Library》]
Coming up, Jonathan Goldstein and his own father. Quien es mas macho? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，乔纳森·戈德斯坦和他的父亲。谁更阳刚？那在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Image Makers, stories of people and institutions who are worried what the world thinks of them, and who take action, decisive action. In this half of the show, we have a son who wants to know what his father makes of him, and a father who needs a little image boost with his own son. Let's move on to Act Two of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目，“形象制造者”，关于那些担心世界怎么看他们，并采取行动、果断行动的人和机构的故事。在节目的这一半，我们有一位想知道他父亲如何看待他的儿子，还有一位在他儿子面前需要一点形象提升的父亲。让我们进入我们节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Goldstein On Goldstein. This second story's a subject that perhaps we don't get enough of here on the public radio: manliness. I find that even the men I know who you think would be least concerned with manliness are still completely concerned with it.
第二幕，“戈德斯坦论戈德斯坦”。这第二个故事是一个我们在这里的公共广播中可能谈论不够的主题：男子气概。我发现即使是我认识的那些你认为最不关心男子气概的男人，他们仍然完全关心它。
I have this friend, Michael, who is constantly talking about what is manly and what is not manly. If you do something that he thinks is impressive, the way that he tells you that he thinks it's impressive is he says to you, very manly. He says it all the time. And he's gay. He's a gay. It's almost like being a gay has made him more obsessed with manliness than any of my straight friends. If you're a man, I think it just comes with the territory.
我有这个朋友，迈克尔，他一直在谈论什么是阳刚，什么是不阳刚。如果你做了一件他认为令人印象深刻的事，他告诉你的方式就是说：非常阳刚。他总是这么说。而他是同性恋。他是个男同性恋。这几乎就像做同性恋让他比我任何直男朋友都更痴迷于男子气概。如果你是个男人，我想这只是随之而来的。
Jonathan Goldstein's been thinking about his own manliness lately. He has this story.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦最近一直在思考他自己的男子气概。他有这个故事。
I've always assumed that my father, Buzz Goldstein, has never seen me as an especially manly guy. As a kid, I did not play sports. I had no interest in tools, and I did not dream of muscle cars. My father, though, was an old-school manly man.
我一直以为我的父亲，巴兹·戈德斯坦，从来没觉得我是个特别阳刚的男人。小时候，我不玩体育运动。我对工具没兴趣，也不梦想开肌肉车。然而，我的父亲是一个老派的硬汉。
Growing up, I watched him charm his way out of traffic tickets, whistle for cabs, and say things like va-va-voom, all things I cannot now help but think of as being a part of a manliness from a bygone era. When he poured whiskey, it was always into a washed-out mustard jar, and it was always at least three or four ounces in a shot. Or the way he had of saying, "Listen pal" in his undershirt and flip-flops, his very extended finger, as rigid as a pool cue, aimed straight at your face, never failed to let you know, in no uncertain terms, who was the alpha-est male in the room. Even the random things my father did seemed drenched in a kind of casual, hairy-knuckled machismo. Like, the fact that he liked grape soda made that soda seem infinitely more barrel-chested than a gutless glass of strawberry pop or a [? fay ?] can of nectar.
成长过程中，我看着他用魅力摆脱交通罚单，为出租车打口哨，并说出“哇哇”之类的词，所有这些我如今不禁认为属于某种过往时代的男子气概。当他倒威士忌时，总是倒进一个洗干净的芥末罐里，一次至少倒三四盎司。或者他穿着汗衫和人字拖说“听着，伙计”的样子，他那根极度伸出的手指，像台球杆一样僵硬，直指你的脸，从没错过让你知道，毫无疑问，谁是房间里最顶级的雄性。甚至我父亲做的随意事情似乎都浸透了一种随意的、长满汗毛的硬汉气概。比如，他喜欢葡萄苏打水的事实，让那种苏打水看起来比一杯胆怯的草莓汽水或一罐花蜜看起来更雄壮。
Another thing that I consider manly about my father is that he is a loud man. He is genetically incapable of whispering. When we go to movies, he will turn to me right in the middle and say, just like we were sitting alone, "Isn't that the guy who played the father on The Rockford Files?"
我认为我父亲男子气概的另一件事是他是一个大嗓门的男人。他基因上无法耳语。当我们去看电影时，他会在中间直接转向我说，就像我们独自坐着一样，“那不是在《洛克福德档案》里扮演父亲的那个家伙吗？”
My dad is now 70, and he still keeps curling weights beside his bed. I am 35, and my own brand of manliness, a gentler, less in your face and, dare I say, woosier form of manliness, is something I've always attributed to a generational difference between my father and me. My father grew up in the Bronx in the '40s, a time and place where threatening out your window to strangle someone's barking dog was merely a friendly morning hello. I wanted to talk with my father about the things that he holds to be manly, and maybe in so doing, figure out what it was that I lacked back then, and still lack to this day.
我爸爸现在70岁了，他床边还放着用来练肱二头肌的哑铃。我35岁，我自己的男子气概——一种更温和、不那么咄咄逼人，甚至可以说更软弱的男子气概——是我一直归因于我和父亲之间代际差异的东西。我父亲在40年代的布朗克斯长大，那个时代和地点，在窗外威胁要勒死某人的吠叫的狗仅仅是一个友好的清晨问候。我想和父亲谈谈他认为阳刚的事情，也许通过这样做，能弄清楚我当时缺少什么，以及至今仍缺少什么。
Do you think there's certain things that a man should know how to do, like how to handle himself? Should he know how to box a little bit?
你认为男人应该知道怎么做某些事吗，比如怎么处理他自己？他应该知道怎么打一点拳击吗？
Yes. Yeah. A man should know how to defend himself. In other words, a man should not have to take any guff from anybody.
是的。是的。男人应该知道怎么保护自己。换句话说，男人不应该忍受任何人的气。
And my father doesn't. Whereas, above my head, there is a sign that reads, please deposit guff.
而我的父亲不会。然而，在我的头顶上，有一块标牌写着：请存放气。
When I was eight, my father decided to teach me how to box. We stood in the foyer of our apartment, knuckle to knuckle, the transgressiveness of it making me giddy and, as my mother would say, overheated. To my eight-year-old brain, the idea of play-fighting with my father ranked somewhere between eating a sidewalk-length roll of candy buttons and watching the Globetrotters on the Wide World of Sports.
我八岁时，父亲决定教我打拳击。我们站在公寓的门厅里，指关节碰着指关节，这种背德感让我头晕目眩，而且正如我母亲所说，过热。对我八岁的大脑来说，和父亲假打的想法排在吃一卷人行道长的糖果钮扣和看《全球体育大观》里的环球旅行者之间。
My father stood beneath the chandelier, dodging, weaving, and jabbing, like a young Willie Pep. I thought this was great. With my arms doing a kind of Dutch windmill, I leapt into the fray, and almost immediately, my mouth connected with one of his fists. My lip split and began to leak blood all over the powder blue, shag carpeting. I started to cry.
父亲站在吊灯下，躲闪、编织、刺拳，就像年轻时的威利·佩普。我觉得这太棒了。我的手臂像荷兰风车一样摆动，我冲进战斗，几乎立刻，我的嘴撞上了他的拳头之一。我的嘴唇裂开了，开始往粉蓝色的长绒地毯上流血。我开始哭。
Then I have this memory of my mother on my father's back, pulling at his hair in a crazed attempt to keep him from mauling me. I cried even harder. I was crying because I had never been hit in the face before, and the pain was so completely new and alien to me. But I was also crying because I felt so bad for my father. Here he was, just trying out his brand of father and son kibitzing with his kid, and now he had to deal with my blood on his hands.
然后我有这个关于我母亲在我父亲背上的记忆，疯狂地拉扯他的头发，试图阻止他伤害我。我哭得更厉害了。我哭是因为我以前从未被击中过脸，而那种疼痛对我来说是如此完全陌生和异类。但我也哭是因为我为父亲感到难过。他在这里，只是想和他的孩子试着进行他那种父子间的闲聊，而现在他必须处理我手上的血。
Even so, a few days later at a family get-together, with my father by my side, I couldn't stop myself from showing every single person I met my puffed-out lip. Then, excitedly, I would tell them that it was my father who had given me this puffed-out lip. Our brawl in the foyer would be the last time my father and I would ever play-fight together.
即便如此，几天后在一次家庭聚会上，父亲在我身边，我无法克制自己向我遇到的每个人展示我肿胀的嘴唇。然后，兴奋地，我会告诉他们是我父亲给了我这个肿胀的嘴唇。我们在门厅里的那场斗殴将是我父亲和我最后一次一起假打。
Do you feel that smoking lends a man a certain kind of manliness?
你觉得吸烟给男人一种某种程度的男子气概吗？
Oh, yeah. Don't forget, we grew up with a certain stereotype when we were young.
哦，是的。别忘了，我们年轻时成长在某种刻板印象中。
You might not remember this, but I remember one time we were on our way to, maybe it was a bar mitzvah. We stopped at a gas station to get some gas, and you picked me up a pack of cigarettes. And you said that it's important for a young man to smoke at a social gathering.
你可能不记得这个，但我记得有一次我们在去参加，也许是成年礼的路上。我们在加油站停下来加油，你帮我买了一包烟。你说年轻人参加社交聚会吸烟很重要。
I did? How old were you at the time?
我做了吗？你那时多大？
I was probably about, maybe 19.
我可能大约，也许19岁。
Really? I did, eh? Well, because, probably, at that time, that was my way of thinking. Why did I start smoking? Not because I enjoyed smoking. The reason I smoked was because I was, first of all, I was never as tall as my friends. I was always shorter for my age, and it made me feel taller. It made me feel as if I belonged, and it gave me something to do with my hands.
真的吗？我做了，呃？嗯，因为，可能，在那个时候，那是我的思维方式。我为什么开始吸烟？不是因为我喜欢吸烟。我吸烟的原因是因为我，首先，我从来没像我的朋友们那么高。我总是比同龄人矮，这让我觉得更高。它让我觉得我属于那里，并且它给了我一些事来做我的手。
Wait. Just go back for a second. How did smoking make you feel taller?
等等。回去一下。吸烟怎么让你觉得更高？
Because all the people, at that time, all the people were smoking. My father smoked. My brother was smoking.
因为所有的人，在那个时候，所有的人都在吸烟。我父亲吸烟。我哥哥在吸烟。
How old were you when you started smoking?
你开始吸烟时多大？
15. So I started at a pretty young age.
15岁。所以我开始得很早。
Wait. If I was a taller man, would you have felt that smoking was as important?
等等。如果我是一个更高的男人，你会觉得吸烟很重要吗？
Probably, yes.
可能，是的。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
But still, during my teen years, on the odd occasion when I did smoke, rather than taking my cues from Humphrey Bogart or Danny Zuko, gritting the butt between my teeth like I meant business and ashing often with forceful, deliberate taps, I chose to smoke like David Bowie circa 1972, allowing my cigarette to hang limply from my lips, pretending to be too whacked out on goof balls to care that my ash was six inches long.
但即便如此，在我十几岁的时候，偶尔我吸烟时，与其模仿亨弗莱·鲍嘉或丹尼·祖科，咬紧牙关像个办正事的人，并且用有力、刻意的敲击频繁掸烟灰，我选择像1972年前后的大卫·鲍伊那样吸烟，让我的香烟松弛地挂在嘴唇上，假装被那些药丸搞得太迷糊，不在乎我的烟灰有六英寸长。
My obsession with David Bowie, a languidly, androgynous glam rocker, wasn't something that troubled my father so much as it simply wasn't anything he could understand. My father preferred singers like Joe Cocker, men who deliver their lyrics as though painfully screaming them from a locked toilet stall. In his day, liking someone like David Bowie would have been the domain of degenerate officers in black and white movies about Nazis.
我对大卫·鲍伊这个懒散的、雌雄同体的华丽摇滚歌手的痴迷，并没有让父亲那么困扰，只是他根本无法理解这件事。父亲更喜欢乔·科克那种歌手，那种交付歌词的方式好像是从锁上的厕所隔间里痛苦地尖叫出来的人。在他那个时代，喜欢大卫·鲍伊这样的人会是关于纳粹的黑白电影里堕落军官的领域。
But to this day, whenever I'm over at my parents and Bowie's on Entertainment Tonight, my father will call me over and say, your pal's on TV. And we will both sit there in silence watching David Bowie, both of us wondering what the other one could possibly be thinking.
但至今，每当我在父母家，电视上在放鲍伊时，父亲就会叫我过去说，你的伙伴在电视上。我们俩就会坐在那里沉默地看着大卫·鲍伊，我们俩都在想对方可能在想什么。
The thing is, my father is much more forthright when it comes to letting my friends know what he's thinking. With my friends, he is forthright on a great many subjects.
问题是，我的父亲在让我的朋友们知道他在想什么时要直率得多。对我的朋友们，他在很多话题上都很直率。
If we're downtown, and we're hanging around with one of my friends like, say, Howard, you'll be more inclined to point out a good-looking woman, or something like that, in a way that you probably wouldn't do with me as much.
如果我们在市区，和我的某个朋友待在一起，比如，霍华德，你更倾向于指出一个好看的女人，或类似的事，方式可能和你对我不太一样。
Yeah. I guess I'd feel more comfortable because you're my son. You know, these are things that you don't do with your son. But I've pointed out good-looking women with you, Johnny. I've walked with you. I mean, look, I've got eyes in my head. My father did it with me. He'd look at a woman and say, "Oh boy, va-va-voom!"
是的。我猜我会觉得更舒服，因为你是我的儿子。你知道，这些事你不会和你的儿子做。但我确实和你指出过好看的女人，强尼。我和你走在一起。我是说，看，我头上有眼睛。我父亲对我这样做。他会看着一个女人说，“哦，天哪，哇哇！”
There was one time I remember, where we were walking through, I think it was a parking lot. And I was, maybe, about 18, 19. And we were passing by this other young woman. And you turned to me. And you noticed that that woman looked at me, and you said, "You see that woman over there? I could tell that you could make her."
有一次我记得，我们正走过，我想是在一个停车场。我当时，可能，大约18、19岁。我们正经过另一个年轻女性。你转向我。你注意到那个女人看着我，你说，“你看到那个女人了吗？我能看出来你肯定能搞定她。”
Yeah.
是的。
And then you said, "You see, I could tell these things. You can't tell these kind of things because you're more into books."
然后你说，“你看，我能看出这些事。你看不出这些事，因为你更沉迷于书本。”
You were more preoccupied, yeah. You were more preoccupied. These weren't the things that were of the greatest interest to you.
你更全神贯注，是的。你更全神贯注。这些不是你最感兴趣的事。
And so you thought maybe I would miss something like that?
所以你以为我可能错过那样的东西？
Yeah. I guess I was more aware of these things. You know, as a young man, I went out with a lot of women. I had a lot of experience and I could instinctively tell these things.
是的。我猜我更了解这些事。你知道，作为一个年轻人，我和很多女人出去过。我有过很多经验，我可以本能地看出这些事。
And so how would you characterize that difference between me and you?
那么你会怎么描述我和你之间的那个差异？
I was a different type. I wanted to wear nice clothes, and go out with good-looking women, and drive a nice car. And you were never interested in these sort of things.
我是一个不同类型的人。我想穿漂亮的衣服，和好看的女人出去，开一辆好车。而你从来对这些事没兴趣。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
I've always taken my father saying that I was more into books or I was never into these kinds of things as being a polite way of saying that I just wasn't a regular guy. And I have to say, I've never felt hurt by that, nor have I taken it personally. From a young age, I've always believed that defying familial expectations is an important part of self-actualization. I learned that in books.
我一直把我父亲说我更沉迷于书本或从来对这些事没兴趣当作是一种礼貌的说法，意思是说我只是不是个普通的家伙。我必须说，我从来没因此感到受伤，也没往心里去。从小我就一直相信，违抗家庭期望是自我实现的重要组成部分。我在书里学到了这一点。
Whining is unmanly, complaining and bitching a lot.
抱怨是不阳刚的，抱怨和发牢骚太多。
So do you think there's a certain kind of stoicism, that that's necessary?
所以你认为某种程度的坚忍是必要的吗？
I don't think. It can't be forced. It's either you have it or you don't.
我不认为。它不能强求。要么你有，要么你没有。
When you think of me, do you think of me as possessing a certain quiet manliness?
当你想到我时，你觉得我拥有某种安静的男子气概吗？
Yes.
是的。
No, I want you to be honest.
不，我希望你诚实。
I'm being honest, Johnny, because I feel that you have done a lot of things that I wish I had done when I was younger. You were more assertive with things that you didn't-- you see, I went along with things a lot, whereas you didn't. You see?
我很诚实，强尼，因为我觉得你做了很多事，我希望我年轻时也做了。你对那些事更自信……你看，我经常随波逐流，而你没有。你看？
Let me give you an example of what I mean. You know my mother was a very domineering woman, even after I married. I just accepted the decisions made by them, and that was unmanly, yes.
让我给你举个例子。你知道我母亲是个非常专横的女人，即使在我结婚后。我只是接受了他们做的决定，那是不阳刚的，是的。
My father's mother had talked my father into quitting high school so he could get a job and help support the family. It was a move he always regretted.
我父亲的母亲说服父亲退学，这样他就可以找份工作帮助支持家庭。那是一个他一直后悔的举动。
I remember my father's mother as a small woman with a knack for getting my father to do whatever she wanted. Like, if she needed a lift to the hairdresser in the middle of the day, he would drop everything at once and go. The phone would ring. He would listen in silence, and he would go. Even once my father was married, his mother would still interfere in all sorts of small day-to-day things.
我记得我父亲的母亲是一个小个子女人，有一手让父亲做任何她想做的事的本领。比如，如果她需要在中午搭便车去理发师那儿，他会放下一切立刻去。电话会响。他会沉默地听着，然后他就去了。即使我父亲结婚后，他的母亲仍然会干涉各种各样的小事。
For example, we were shopping one day on Kings Highway, your mother and I, and we saw a cute fireplace. It wasn't a real fireplace, it was an electric fireplace. And we fell in love with it. It was black metal, and we were ready to buy it. And I happened to bring up the topic to my mother and she just pooh-poohed, and just discouraged us, and discouraged me. And then I changed my mind as a result of that. It was impractical. And what do you need this for? And what are you wasting your money on garbage like that?
比如，有一天我们在国王高速公路上购物，你母亲和我，我们看到了一个可爱的壁炉。那不是一个真的壁炉，那是一个电壁炉。我们爱上了它。它是黑色的金属，我们准备买下它。我碰巧把话题提给了我母亲，她直接否定了，只是劝阻我们，劝阻我。然后我因为那个改变了主意。它不切实际。你需要这个干什么？你把钱浪费在那种垃圾上干什么？
And I'll be honest with you, that was unmanly. OK, if you want to talk about being unmanly, that was unmanly. I should have taken a strong position in saying, look, this is between me and my wife. We enjoy this. It's going to give us happiness, and it's none of your business. You know? I respect you. I could have said I love you, but you've got to keep your nose out of my business and what goes on between me and my wife. These are things that I never did. And, if I were like you, my mother would have never gotten away with the things that she did.
我也跟你实话实说，那是不阳刚的。好的，如果你想谈论不阳刚，那是不阳刚的。我应该采取强硬立场说，看，这是我和我妻子之间的事。我们享受它。它会给我们带来幸福，这不关你的事。你知道吗？我尊重你。我本可以跟我说我爱你，但你必须把你的鼻子从我的事和我妻子之间发生的事里拿开。这些是我从来没做过的事。而且，如果我像你一样，我母亲永远不可能逃脱她所做的那些事。
I really didn't expect this. Of course, I've never doubted that my father liked me, but I always felt that it was in spite of what I wasn't and not because of what I was. And what I was was a man who was willing to ignore his own mother.
我真的没料到会这样。当然，我从来没怀疑过父亲喜欢我，但我总是觉得那是在我“不是什么”的情况下，而不是因为我“是什么”。而我所是的，是一个愿意忽视自己母亲的男人。
By the time my father was my age now, he had already served in the Army overseas. He had already entered himself in Golden Glove boxing matches, had two kids, and was working two jobs. And me? When my mother tells me not to put my feet up on the coffee table, I continue to put my feet up on the coffee table. This is what my father is impressed by. This is what makes me a man. I don't want to say this disappoints me, but sometimes I can't help wanting to be manly in exactly the way that he's manly.
当我父亲现在和我一样大时，他已经去海外服过兵役了。他已经参加过金手套拳击比赛，有了两个孩子，并且做了两份工作。而我呢？当我母亲告诉我不要把脚放在咖啡桌上时，我继续把脚放在咖啡桌上。这就是我父亲印象深刻的地方。这就是让我成为男人的原因。我不想说这让我失望，但有时我不禁想要以他阳刚的方式变得阳刚。
When I was a child, my father had chronic back pain, and I was very proud of how loud he could yell in agony. So great was his pain and his rage about his pain, that, one night, he actually yanked the bed board off the bed. After it happened, I would brag to my friends about how strong my father was. From then on, whenever I pulled off some unexpected physical tour de force, like opening a stuck jar of Nutella, my face as red and squinty as a clenched fist, my friends would say that I was pulling out the Goldstein bed board. That's the kind of manly I want to be. That's when I feel at one with my legacy.
当我还是个孩子时，父亲有长期的背痛，我非常自豪他能因痛苦而喊得有多大声。他的痛苦和对他痛苦的愤怒如此之大，以至于有一天晚上，他实际上把床板从床上扯了下来。事情发生后，我会向朋友们吹嘘我父亲有多强壮。从那时起，每当我做出一些意想不到的身体奇迹时，比如打开一罐卡住的榛子酱，我的脸红得像个紧握的拳头，朋友们就会说我是在拔出“戈德斯坦床板”。那就是我想成为的那种阳刚。那是我感觉与我的遗产合而为一时。
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of the radio show, Wire Tap, on the CBC, and the author of the novel, Lenny Bruce is Dead.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦是CBC电台节目《Wire Tap》的主持人，也是小说《兰尼·布鲁斯死了》的作者。
All right. Talk at the volume you're going to be speaking in.
好了。用你即将说话的音量说话。
This is the volume that I'm going to be speaking in.
这是我即将说话的音量。
Why don't we start off by giving me a real listen pal.
我们为什么不从给我一个真实的“听着，伙计”开始呢？
Listen pal, when I speak, I like people to listen to me and pay attention to what I'm saying. Do you understand what I'm saying? Do you hear me?
听着，伙计，当我说话时，我喜欢人们听我说并注意我在说什么。你明白我在说什么吗？你听到我了吗？
Give me a listen pal along with imagining that someone just cut in front of you in line.
给我一个“听着，伙计”，同时想象有人刚刚插队插在你前面。
Listen, pal. Do you know there's a line? We've all been waiting here for quite a while. There's a line that goes in the back. You don't start here in the middle or go to the front, you go to the back.
听着，伙计。你知道有排队吗？我们大家都已经在那里等了很久了。有一条排队到后面。你不要从中间或前面开始，你要去后面。
All right. Now you have to get a little bit more aggressive because he's not listening to you.
好了。现在你必须变得更有侵略性一点，因为他没在听你说。
Hey! What are you, dense? Don't you hear what I'm saying to you? You don't listen? Don't ignore me. Don't ignore me because I'm not going to let you go in front of me. Don't ignore me. That only infuriates me.
嘿！你是笨蛋吗？你没听到我在跟你说什么吗？你没在听吗？不要忽视我。不要忽视我，因为我不会让你走到我前面的。不要忽视我。那只会让我暴怒。
And that's the last thing he wants to do.
而那是他最不想做的事。
That's right.
没错。
[MUSIC - "I'M WAITING FOR THE MAN" BY DAVID BOWIE]
[音乐 - 大卫·鲍伊的《I'm Waiting for the Man》]
Act Three, Heart Shaped Box. Seven years ago, Doug Hill was diagnosed with a rare brain disease called frontal lobe dementia. On our show a while back, we had a story about Doug's son, Nick, who was very young at the time and struggling to understand the disease.
第三幕，“心形盒”。七年前，道格·希尔被诊断出患有一种罕见的脑部疾病，叫额颞叶痴呆。在我们的节目之前，我们有一个关于道格的儿子尼克的报道，尼克当时非常小，正努力理解这种疾病。
His disease slowly shrinks your brain. Your personality goes, your logic, your emotions. It's pretty brutal, and it's fatal. About a year ago, Doug got much worse and his family started preparing for the end. And, as you might understand, it's been a long, slow, complicated goodbye over the years that he has deteriorated.
他的疾病慢慢萎缩你的大脑。你的个性消失了，你的逻辑，你的情绪。这很残酷，而且是致命的。大约一年前，道格变得更糟了，他的家人开始为终局做准备。而且，你可能理解，这多年来一直是一个漫长、缓慢、复杂的告别，他一直在恶化。
The therapist said that, for Nick to find closure, for Nick, especially to understand his feelings when his dad finally died, what he was going to need is a picture in his head of who his dad really was back when he was well. Doug needed to be real if Nick was going to be able to let him go. And the job of producing this important biography of this person who Nick, kind of, didn't exactly really know anymore, fell to Nick's mom, Julie.
治疗师说，尼克要找到解脱，尼克要理解他父亲最终去世时的感受，他需要的是在他脑海里有一幅关于他父亲在健康时到底是谁的画面。如果尼克要能够让他离开，道格需要是真实的。而制作这个重要的人物传记的工作——那个尼克某种程度上已经不再真正认识的人——落到了尼克的母亲朱莉身上。
My son is 10 years old. He's tall, and thin, and blonde, and freckled, and smart, and funny, and generous. In other words, Nick is his father all over again. Yet, Nick knows so little about his dad. He's too young to remember what Doug was like before he got sick.
我儿子10岁。他个子高，瘦，金发，有雀斑，聪明，有趣，慷慨。换句话说，尼克就是他父亲的翻版。然而，尼克对他爸爸了解得太少。他太小了，不记得道格生病前是什么样子。
His father was far more than the early symptoms of the disease, like Doug constantly repeating himself, or compulsively eating every sweet in sight, or irrationally walking in front of moving traffic. So giving this complete picture of Doug, this hugely important job, falls to me. I'm 43 years old and both my parents are alive. That makes me supremely unqualified, not to mention overwhelmed. I married Doug 20 years ago. Where do I even start? Apparently, with objects.
他的父亲远不止疾病的早期症状，比如道格不断重复自己，或者强迫性地吃掉视线内的每一点甜食，或者非理性地走在移动的交通面前。所以给出道格这幅完整的图画，这个极其重要的工作，落到了我身上。我43岁，我的父母都还活着。这使我完全没有资格，更不用说不知所措。我20年前嫁给了道格。我从哪里开始呢？显然，从物体开始。
My friend Adrian lost both her parents by the time she was 19. She's told me she still yearns for stuff that her parents touched or carried around, that somehow they connect her to them. So when Doug got sick, Adrian told me to collect simple, everyday items, and that, one day, they'd mean the world to Nick. So early on, Doug's things started making their way into a box, a casket of memories.
我的朋友阿德里安19岁时失去了双亲。她告诉我她仍然渴望父母摸过或随身携带的东西，某种程度上它们将她与他们连接在一起。所以道格生病时，阿德里安告诉我收集简单的日常物品，有一天，它们对尼克来说意义重大。所以很早，道格的东西开始进入一个盒子，一个记忆的棺材。
The box is about the size of a child's shoe box, and it's made of tin. The remnants of all the colors it once was, red, and green, and yellow, poke through its rusty patina. Long ago, it sat in Doug's grandmother's home in the WASP-y end of Indianapolis, and Doug loved it then as much as Nick does now.
那个盒子大约一个儿童鞋盒大小，是锡制的。它曾经所有的颜色，红色、绿色和黄色，透过它锈迹斑斑的铜绿冒出来。很久以前，它坐在道格在印第安纳波利斯沃斯普区祖母的家里，道格那时对它的热爱就像尼克现在一样。
Now the box sits on top of a Barrister bookcase in our hallway. It's deliberately up high so that Nick has to ask a grown-up to get it down. Staying slightly out of reach keeps it precious. Plus, this way, the story that the box contains has a ready narrator. There's no master plan for what's been collected: eyeglasses, a press pass, a passport, pictures. Often I've wondered, how could these things be so important?
现在盒子坐在我们走廊的律师书架上。它特意放得很高，这样尼克就必须请一个成年人把它拿下来。保持稍微够不到的位置让它显得珍贵。另外，这样，盒子包含的故事就有一个随时待命的叙述者。收集的东西没有总体计划：眼镜、记者证、护照、照片。我经常想，这些东西怎么会如此重要？
For the first six years after Doug got sick, Nick didn't want to look inside the box. It scared him. But as his daddy got sicker, on Saturday afternoons I started bringing the box down, combing through the stuff myself. Slowly, Nick would tread to my side. And now he calls the box his treasure. But each time Nick and I go through the box, the discussion is different and surprising, never quite going the way I think it will.
道格生病后的前六年，尼克不想往盒子里看。它吓坏了他。但当他的爸爸病得更重时，周六下午我开始把盒子拿下来，自己梳理里面的东西。慢慢地，尼克会走到我身边。现在他把那个盒子称为他的财宝。但每次尼克和我翻看那个盒子时，讨论都是不同且令人惊讶的，从来没有完全按照我以为的方式进行。
One of the smaller items in the box is a laminated work ID with CNN's logo. It has Doug's name and the title Video Journalist on it, plus an amazingly handsome picture of him at 22 years old. When Nick pulled it out, it seemed like a great opportunity to make Doug human. I told Nick how his dad was a studio cameraman there, and how, one night, the handle on the camera's wheeled pedestal hooked onto Doug's belt loop as he walked away. Doug's camera was live, so the anchorman and the whole newsdesk had to list to keep up with Doug's rolling shot.
盒子里较小的物品之一是一张带有CNN标志的层压工作证。上面有道格的名字和“视频记者”的头衔，加上一张他22岁时令人惊叹的英俊照片。当尼克把它拿出来时，这似乎是一个让道格变得人性化的绝佳机会。我告诉尼克他爸爸是怎么在那里当录影棚摄影师，以及有一天，摄影机轮式底座上的手柄在道格走开时钩住了他的皮带扣。道格的摄影机是直播的，所以主播和整个新闻台不得不倾斜着以跟上道格的推车镜头。
Nick laughed a little, but he steered the conversation in a totally different direction. "Did daddy ever work for Fox News?" "No, never." "Oh, thank God. Daddy was a Democrat." And while I thought Nick might want to know his dad was capable of making a goofy mistake, what Nick took away from the work ID was that his daddy leaned left.
尼克笑了笑，但他把谈话引导向了完全不同的方向。“爸爸给福克斯新闻工作过吗？”“没有，从来没有。”“哦，感谢上帝。爸爸是民主党人。”虽然我以为尼克可能想知道他爸爸有能力犯一个愚蠢的错误，但尼克从工作证中带走的是他爸爸偏左。
Nick loves looking at the pictures, pictures of Doug, especially when he was a kid, when he was 10 in Florida, and when he was 12, sitting at a birthday party with his namesake grandfather. And even more precious are the pictures of Nick and Doug together. There's one of Doug holding our very surprised 18-month-old boy upside down. And one shows Nick as a toddler sitting on his dad's lap as they steer a boat. Yet another shows them sleeping next to each other with Nick curled against his dad.
尼克喜欢看照片，道格的照片，尤其是他小时候，当他在佛罗里达10岁时，以及当他12岁时，坐在生日派对上和同名的爷爷在一起时。更珍贵的是尼克和道格在一起的照片。有一张是道格把我们非常惊讶的18个月大的儿子倒过来抱着。还有一张显示尼克作为一个蹒跚学步的孩子坐在他爸爸膝盖上，他们驾驶着一艘船。还有一张显示他们睡在一起，尼克蜷缩在他爸爸身边。
The questions come again. "When did that happen?" I try to remember as many details as I can. "We were playing hide-and-seek in the living room when Daddy started swinging you around." "We drove a golf cart to the marina in Florida the day we went out on Uncle Larry's boat. And when you napped together, we were at a beach house near Charleston."
问题再次出现。“那是什么时候发生的？”我尽量记住我能记住的所有细节。“当爸爸开始把你转来转去时，我们正在客厅里玩捉迷藏。”“那天我们坐高尔夫球车去了佛罗里达的码头，我们上了拉里叔叔的船。当我们在一起小睡时，我们在查尔斯顿附近的一个海滩小屋。”
At the bottom of the box hides Doug's wedding ring. It came off years ago when his hand swelled and the ring cut off circulation. Nick loves to touch it, sliding this metal hula hoop around his number two-pencil fingers.
盒子底部藏着道格的结婚戒指。它是几年前当他的手肿胀，戒指切断循环时摘下来的。尼克喜欢触摸它，把这个金属呼啦圈套在他二号铅笔手指上滑动。
But some of the objects in the box aren't as popular as others. Nick has never put on Doug's eyeglasses. Cuff links and tuxedo studs sit untouched along with the antique pocket watch I bought Doug for our 10th wedding anniversary. But time and again, it's clear that my friend Adrian was right: sometimes throw-away items have the most meaning.
但盒子里的一些物品不如其他的受欢迎。尼克从来没戴过道格的眼镜。袖扣和燕尾服钉扣和我在我们结婚十周年纪念日给道格买的古董怀表一样，都没被动过。但时而，显而易见，我的朋友阿德里安是对的：有时丢弃的物品最有意义。
A few months ago, Nick wanted new toys. The policy in our house is he buys toys for himself with his own allowance money. He'd been eyeing some Dungeons & Dragons figures and was short by $10. He was greatly disappointed, not wanting to wait a few more paydays. Then I almost saw the light bulb flash over Nick's head. "I know. I could use the money from Daddy's change jar."
几个月前，尼克想要新玩具。我们家的政策是他用自己的零花钱买玩具。他一直在看一些《龙与地下城》模型，还差10美元。他非常失望，不想再等几个发薪日。然后我几乎看到灯泡在尼克头顶闪亮。“我知道了。我可以用爸爸零钱罐里的钱。”
When Doug was well, each night he'd come home from work, drop his wallet on the table, and dump his change into a blue ceramic jar. Sometime after Doug moved to the nursing home four years ago, the change jar found a new job: it holds up a family portrait that had lost its easel. This jar has hid on my mantle in plain sight for years, forgotten, at least by me. I pulled it down.
当道格健康时，每天晚上他从工作回家，把钱包丢在桌子上，把零钱倒进一个蓝色陶瓷罐里。道格四年前搬到疗养院后不久，零钱罐找到了新工作：它撑起了一张失去支架的家庭肖像。这个罐子在我壁炉架上明显的地方藏了好几年，被遗忘了，至少对我而言。我把它拿下来。
For more than an hour, our hands got dirty counting the change that once sat in Doug's pockets. We separated the pennies from the dimes and the quarters from the nickles. And we found things like a New York City subway token, and Canadian pennies, and a receipt for a haircut from 1998. The entire time we talked about his dad, the man I made this beautiful boy with.
超过一个小时，我们的手变得脏兮兮，数着曾经在道格口袋里的零钱。我们把便士和角币分开，四分之一美元和五分镍币分开。我们发现了诸如纽约地铁代币、加拿大便士和1998年的理发收据之类的东西。整个过程中，我们都在谈论他爸爸，那个和我生下这个美丽男孩的男人。
We counted up more than $50, a fortune to a fourth grader. Nick was amazed. "What would Daddy want me to do with all this money?" "Well, he'd probably want you to save some, then spend some on fun, like those toys you really want." Nick was thrilled, aching for his new toys.
我们数出了超过50美元，对于一个四年级学生来说是一笔财富。尼克很惊讶。“爸爸会希望我用所有这些钱做什么？”“嗯，他可能会希望你存一些，然后花一些在乐趣上，比如那些你真正想要的玩具。”尼克很激动，渴望着他的新玩具。
On Saturday, we made the trip to the bank and then bought his heart's desire. Back home, Nick ripped open the boxes, joyous for the score, but 10 minutes later he came to me with regretful eyes. "What's wrong, Nick?" He sighed, and swallowed hard, and began to cry. "Daddy's money isn't in the house any more." Pennies, dimes, and nickels, stuff he'd barely bend over to pick up. He felt he'd betrayed his father treating those coins merely as currency. I held him. I tried explaining that these toys, the money in the bank, these were like gifts from his father. But it didn't help. "Those coins were Daddy's, and they'll never be here again."
周六，我们去了银行，然后买了他们的心愿。回到家，尼克撕开了包装盒，为这笔收获感到快乐，但10分钟后他带着后悔的眼睛来到我身边。“怎么了，尼克？”他叹了口气，吞咽得很辛苦，开始哭泣。“爸爸的钱不在房子里了。”便士、角币和镍币，他甚至懒得弯腰去捡的东西。他感到背叛了他的父亲，只是把那些硬币当作货币。我抱着他。我试着解释那些玩具，银行里的钱，这些就像是他父亲的礼物。但这没用。“那些硬币是爸爸的，它们再也不会在这里了。”
We've lost so much of Doug already. Long ago, we let go of his humor, his writings, his displays of love and kindness. Inch by inch, we've buried him, with each day bringing yet another tiny, unbearable loss. So losing these little things, even just pennies, it's the last straw. It's why the box is so important. It's where these treasures from Doug remain safe for Nick, for Nick, but not for me. I have a different treasure trove of Doug's love, and he stands right next to me. He's tall, and thin, and blonde, and freckled, and smart, and funny, and generous, and he's 10 years old.
我们已经失去了道格的太多东西。很久以前，我们放手了他的幽默、他的写作、他的爱和善良的展示。一寸一寸地，我们埋葬了他，每一天都带来又一个微小、难以承受的损失。所以失去这些小东西，即使只是便士，也是最后一根稻草。这就是盒子如此重要的原因。它是这些来自道格的宝藏对尼克保持安全的地方，对尼克而言，但对我不是。我有另一个道格的爱之宝库，而他就站在我身边。他个子高，瘦，金发，有雀斑，聪明，有趣，慷慨，而他10岁。
Julie Hill, in Chicago. Three months after she put together this story, Doug finally died.
朱莉·希尔，在芝加哥。她编排这个故事三个月后，道格终于去世了。
Well, our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
好了，我们的节目今天由黛安·库克和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·科尼格和丽莎·波拉克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
You know, you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who is actually sitting right in our studio today. For once, he's right here. Torey, why don't you just get over to this mic. Right here. Don't be nervous. Here, I'll open your mic.
WBEZ管理监督我们的节目由托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他今天实际上正坐在我们的演播室里。难得，他就在这儿。托里，你为什么不直接到这个麦克风这里来。就在这儿。别紧张。这儿，我打开你的麦克风。
Dar! Flar! Figgy floo! Vee floogle ooh! Flogalo vase!
哒！夫拉！菲吉夫露！微夫露果呜！夫洛加洛花瓶！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。